[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hablamos en términos económicos en
términos políticos ya sería otra cosa
durante al menos las dos últimas décadas
el perú se ha convertido en todo un
referente para los países
latinoamericanos
[Música]
es que con altas tasas de crecimiento
económico y una elevada apertura
comercial durante los últimos años perú
ha experimentado una enorme reducción de
la pobreza y ha visto como la clase
media ha crecido a lo largo y ancho de
todo el país sin embargo amigos esperad
un momento porque esta especie de
círculo virtuoso podría estar agotado y
no sólo eso a lo largo de todos estos
años aunque las cosas han marchado
razonablemente bien algunos problemas
han persistido por ejemplo la enorme
dependencia de las materias primas la
falta de diversificación o la
incapacidad para incorporarse a las
cadenas de producción global
[Música]
y todo esto nos lleva a plantearnos
algunas preguntas logrará el perú
superar este agotamiento y emular a los
tigres asiáticos podrá el país
incorporarse a la cuarta revolución
industrial por qué diantres aún no ha
conseguido el perú superar su
dependencia de las materias primas en
este vídeo vamos a tratar de contestar a
todas estas cuestiones pero antes antes
amigos tenemos que echar un vistazo a
cuáles han sido los ingredientes del
despegue del perú
[Música]
los cimientos del buje peruano
que ha impulsado el éxito peruano de los
últimos 25 años esta es una pregunta
importantísima para el perú para el
resto de países latinoamericanos y
prácticamente para cualquier persona que
quiere ver a su país escapar de la
pobreza
[Música]
pues amigos para responder a esta
pregunta podemos destacar dos grandes
cuestiones la primera de ellas es la
ortodoxia y la estabilidad
macroeconómica no tranquilos no es algo
para nada aburrido veréis una de las
claves del empuje del perú es que los
diferentes gobiernos han apostado por la
continuidad no habrá segunda vuelta el
presidente de la república ha sido
reelecto no estoy dispuesto a darle la
espalda a mi país ni a la democracia es
decir han tenido diferencias políticas
sí claro como todos esto es inevitable y
además es hasta bueno pero entendieron
que había un modelo de desarrollo un
modelo de país que no se tenía que tocar
alberto fujimori alejandro toledo alan
garcía en su segunda etapa claro
ollanta humala pedro pablo kuczynski y
ahora martín vizcarra seis presidentes
con diferentes planteamientos políticos
pero básicamente con un mismo modelo
económico esto me recuerda al señor de
los anillos' lo que pasa es que en vez
de un anillo sería un modelo un modelo
para gobernarlos a todos este debate le
sirva a ustedes queridos compatriotas el
caso es que durante los últimos 25 años
el perú ha tenido bajo control los
déficit y la deuda pública han respetado
la independencia del banco central y
evitado la tentación de darle a la
máquina de imprimir billetes y en
general han promovido la inversión
echemos por ejemplo un vistazo a la
evolución que ha tenido la entrada de
inversión extranjera en el país veréis
entre 1980 y 1994 word apenas se duplicó
entre el 94 y 2005 se multiplicó por 4 y
entre 2005 y la actualidad casi se ha
multiplicado por siete es decir la
apuesta extranjera en el perú cada vez
ha crecido más en menos tiempo
[Música]
todo esto amigos es lo que ha hecho que
las tasas de crecimiento en perú hayan
promediado casi un 6% anual durante más
de 15 años fijaos
[Música]
en una reunión de la apec me preguntaron
que creía que iba a pasar con la
economía peruana y la crisis
internacional y yo decía que lo único
que estaba seguro era de que el país que
más iba a crecer este año iba a ser el
perú
luís alberto moreno presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo
por supuesto cuando hay crecimiento
económico es algo que de una forma u
otra termina favoreciendo a casi todo el
mundo creo que aquí no hay que ser
premio nobel de economía para entenderlo
[Música]
en perú en menos de 15 años un periodo
de tiempo corto la capacidad adquisitiva
per cápita casi se duplicó en 15 años y
la pobreza cayó en 30 30 puntos
porcentuales
[Música]
pero como con los porcentajes a veces
nos perdemos para comprender realmente
la importancia que ha tenido semejante
reducción de la pobreza creo que es
mejor hablar de personas 77 millones de
peruanos abandonaron la pobreza en menos
de 15 años gracias al crecimiento
económico del país
[Música]
pero junto a la estabilidad y
continuidad macroeconómica la otra
apuesta estratégica ha sido la apertura
al exterior
[Música]
de shanghai a chancay
comenzó en los 90 continuó con el cambio
de siglo y mantiene su vigencia en
nuestros días
hoy perú tiene acuerdos de libre
comercio ni más ni menos que con las
tres grandes zonas económicas del mundo
con eeuu con china y con la unión
europea también forma parte de la
alianza del pacífico y en general su
política exterior está muy dirigida a
lograr nuevos acuerdos comerciales y
todo esto claro es algo que ha tenido
consecuencias
las exportaciones han aumentado desde
los 3.000 millones de dólares en 1990 a
más de 52 mil millones hoy en día es
decir se ha multiplicado por 17
sin embargo amigos espera un momento no
no lances todavía las campanas al vuelo'
vale si los resultados han sido
fantásticos esto es verdad pero ahora el
modelo el modelo parece un pelín agotado
en un pasado vídeo aquí en visual
político ya os contamos muchas cosas
buenas del perú hoy queremos echar un
vistazo a las cosas no tan buenas si ya
sabéis que aquí en este canal nos
encanta nos mola mucho contar las cosas
buenas de los países y desde luego pero
tiene muchas muchísimas cosas buenas
pero amigos si no miramos al otro lado
si no miramos la otra cara de la moneda
al final esto puede terminar fatal a lo
enron al o nokia a logo weeks ahí es
donde yo veo una gran oportunidad
también es decir dejándote un castañazo
así que como decimos por aquí dicho y
hecho
veamos cuáles son los principales
problemas que hacen que el país no
consiga emular a los tigres a los
dragones del continente asiático atentos
[Música]
el perú que frena pero todavía no ha
conseguido escapar de la pobreza a pesar
de estos casi 25 años de crecimiento
ininterrumpido el país sigue teniendo
mucha pobreza
y lo peor de todo es que a pesar de ello
en los últimos tiempos bueno podemos
decir que la economía peruana parece un
globo con una ligera fuga de aire que
podría hacerse mucho más grande
pero sigue creciendo pero la
desaceleración es más que evidente el
país crece menos y la confianza entre
los empresarios se ha reducido un montón
pero eso no es lo más grave lo peor es
que los grandes cambios están tardando
en llegar mucho más de lo que se
esperaba en el país todavía hay mucha
muchísima pobreza y a pesar de todo el
crecimiento siguen sin tener una
economía productiva diversificada y
moderna
esencialmente perú sigue dependiendo de
las materias primas y ahora si el
crecimiento se desacelerará la pregunta
es cuánto van a tardar en cambiar las
cosas
pero cómo diantres podemos explicar que
lograr cambios en este país cueste tanto
pues amigos aquí van algunas ideas
[Música]
pongan luz aunque usted un número a su
primer gobierno que desgraciados usted
yo me jala jala al que le diga si usted
se jala sin mí como presidente porque
debemos gustar entonces ahora porque
usted y yo a mi hijo y le dije en que el
culo [ __ ] de colon americano sabe el
primer problema creo que esto es una de
esas veces donde cada vez vamos a estar
todos de acuerdo es político el primer
problema es político empezando por la
corrupción
[Música]
la cosa está chunga está tan mal que al
menos los últimos cinco presidentes del
país son sospechosos o están
involucrados en casos de corrupción tres
están en la cárcel fujimori humala y
kuczynski toledo parece que está camino
de ella y luego alan garcía bueno seguro
que ya sabéis todo es el trágico final
que desgraciadamente tuvo alan garcía ex
presidente del perú fallece tras
dispararse a sí mismo antes de ser
arrestado pero este no es el único
berenjenal político en perú los partidos
se llevan tan mal la política está tan
polarizada y fragmentada que los
acuerdos son tan difíciles como imaginar
una candidatura presidencial compuesta
por mauricio macri y cristina fernández
de kirchner bueno la verdad es que ahora
que lo pienso está igual no sería tan
difícil de ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sí
el caso es que claro esta enorme
polarización ha hecho que la agenda de
reformas económicas esté de facto metida
en el congelador desde la crisis
internacional el país apenas ha sacado
adelante ninguna reforma estructural de
calado
[Música]
ojo hay quien defiende que esta falta de
capacidad de los gobiernos y el congreso
tuvo en su día algo bastante bueno el
que las reformas económicas de los 90 se
mantuvieron en el tiempo por la poca
capacidad de acción de la clase política
es decir que este inmovilismo es lo que
podría haberles impedido a los políticos
cambiar el rumbo económico del país y la
estabilidad que hemos comentado pero
claro el problema es que el tiempo pasa
y si necesita más
pero no sólo eso al final entre la
corrupción y la incapacidad para llegar
a acuerdos los políticos peruanos han
conseguido que el perú se convierta en
el país de latinoamérica que menos
confianza tienen sus organizaciones
políticas en otras palabras que tal y
como están las cosas los peruanos le
darían antes las llaves de su casa al
mismísimo vito corleone o a darth vader
ya sus propios políticos
[Música]
el segundo problema es que la aparente
buena marcha de la economía del país por
así decirlo ha tapado escondido
camuflado otras cuestiones que no han
evolucionado también una de ellas es la
productividad que no sólo no ha mejorado
sino que incluso desde 1975 ha tenido
una evolución negativa si se lo habéis
escuchado bien una evolución negativa en
el largo plazo el resultado neto muestra
un estancamiento secular en la
productividad en el perú esto es la
causa principal de la falta de
convergencia de su ingreso per cápita
con el de las economías más avanzadas
marta ruiz a rafa asesora económica del
bid ahora bien por qué es esto tan
importante pues amigos de visual polític
para verlo claro con los datos en la
mano esto quiere decir que un solo
trabajador estadounidense es tan
productivo como cinco trabajadores
peruanos y claro es que así no se puede
hace 70 años esta cifra no era de 5 sino
de 3
un trabajador de eeuu era tres veces más
productivo que un trabajador peruano hoy
es cinco veces más
ojo esto no quiere decir que los
peruanos trabajen menos sino que en el
país se han creado puestos de trabajo de
muy bajo valor añadido que generan poco
y esto claro se debe a problemas
estructurales como por ejemplo la
incapacidad para atraer inversión de
alto valor añadido la falta de
competencia la sensación de inseguridad
jurídica la falta de emprendimiento
problemas con las infraestructuras que
son un desastre etcétera etcétera
sorprendido sorprendida pues no deberías
de hecho no es el único factor que ha
tenido una evolución mala fijaos cómo ha
evolucionado el perú en el ranking de
competitividad mundial
y es que precisamente uno de los
secretos de las economías asiáticas es
que si empezaron a especializarse en
actividades de poco valor añadido es
decir para entendernos competían en
salarios bajos pero al mismo tiempo
siempre han tratado de mejorar su nivel
de competitividad
y eso pero como veis pues no ha sido así
esto es lo que explica que las
exportaciones tradicionales las de toda
la vida los metales el petróleo la
harina de pescado representen más del 70
por ciento de todas las exportaciones
peruanas por cierto una pequeña maldad
os imagináis que diría un líder político
peruano viendo este vídeo seguro que
algo así como para ver si las cosas van
bien más quieren el país crece venezuela
está mucho peor nada nada está todo bien
venga dale rapidito vamos a terminar con
esto que es la hora de la siesta o del
fútbol o de lo que díaz / sea
por ejemplo uno de los ámbitos en los
que podemos ver el resultado de esta
especie de pasotismo es precisamente en
la educación un pilar imprescindible
para la modernización de todo país
pues bien tras 25 años de fuerte
crecimiento económico el sistema
educativo peruano sigue teniendo más
agujeros que un queso gruyère según el
bid el banco interamericano de
desarrollo tan solo el 30 por ciento de
las infraestructuras educativas pueden
ser consideradas adecuadas en fin amigos
estos son los principales problemas a
los que se enfrenta el país pero como el
perú ha hecho también muchas cosas bien
en los últimos años no podemos terminar
el vídeo con un mensaje tan negativo así
que veamos
pero en marcha
amigos a pesar de los problemas el perú
es verdad ha sido uno de los países con
el mejor desempeño económico de toda
latinoamérica durante las últimas tres
décadas como vimos antes el nivel de
pobreza ha caído a toda velocidad y eso
es una de las mejores noticias posibles
[Música]
asimismo entre el 2011 y el 2017 la
clase media pasó de aproximadamente 9
millones 847 mil personas a casi 13
millones y medio esto supone una
expansión de casi el 40 40% en poco más
de 5 años y aunque se ha desacelerado lo
cierto es que el país sigue siendo el
que más crece de toda la alianza del
pacífico
[Música]
en fin con este vídeo hemos querido
poner sobre la mesa los motivos que
explican por qué al perú le está
costando más de lo esperado dar el gran
salto pero ahora te toca a ti crees que
el perú logrará finalmente emular el
éxito de los dragones asiáticos déjame
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante darle al
botón de like y no olvides suscribirte a
visual político un saludo y nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo
no estoy dispuesto a darle la espalda a
mi país ni a la democracia de la ceja la
que le diga si usted deja la símil como
presidente porque debemos mostrar
entonces ahora por qué